[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 mardi 3 octobre
les titres de cette édition c'est le 23e
lieu du genre en france ouvert il ya un
an l'espace ça bébés parents de
guyancourt a été inauguré officiellement
hier un dispositif d'accompagnement pour
les familles vulnérables on sait par la
croix rouge
on en parle sur ce plateau avec jean-luc
le guislain président de l'unité locale
de la croix rouge de saint quentin en
yvelines dans ce journal nous vous
présenterons également une colocation
qui a ouvert ses portes récemment à
versailles particularité ce mode de vie
et de partage et proposer à des
personnes atteintes d'un handicap mental
cinq jeunes bénéficient du concept enfin
comme chaque mardi le portrait de la
rédaction ce soir il est consacré à
l'une des plus importantes figures
associative de saint quentin en yvelines
jean flattot président des amis du passé
et d'elancourt mais avant de développer
ces titres ce cliché impressionnant à
vous montrer ce matin vers 10 heures un
accident impliquant deux bus s'est
produit à elancourt un véhicule de la
société sqy bus en a percuté un autre à
l'arrêt rue du 19 mars 1962 19 personnes
ont été blessées légèrement cinq
hospitalisées leur état n'est pas
préoccupant
une défaillance de freinage serait à
l'origine de cet incident 4000 monuments
protégés en ile-de-france le patrimoine
du territoire est riche mais fragile
hier le conseil régional présenté sa
nouvelle politique en la matière et à
cette occasion une convention de
partenariat a été signée avec la
fondation du patrimoine
l'île de france s'engage à apporter son
aide aux souscription lancée par la
fondation avec une attention
particulière sur le patrimoine de
proximité
chaque euro collecté sera complétée d'un
euros apportés par la région
les précisions de deux yvelinois alain
schmitz et valérie pécresse au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est une aide qui va venir abonder les
budgets des collectivités territoriales
or on sait que les communes rurales
c'est à dire les communes de moins de
2000 habitants n'ont pas aujourd'hui les
moyens financiers pour faire face à ce
type de restauration un euro investi
dans le patrimoine c'est
70 euros de retombées économiques pour
un territoire que ce soit en visite que
ce soit en aménagement du territoire
donc nous nous avons voulu que le
patrimoine soient vivants qu'ils soient
restaurées et qu'il puisse permettre à
l'île de france de rayonner et tous les
territoires sont concernés à la fois le
patrimoine industriel mais aussi le
patrimoine rural
l inquiétude à saint quentin en yvelines
les élus craignent la rumeurs d'abandon
du projet de la ligne 18 du grand paris
express pour raisons budgétaires
quasiment tous sauf les écologistes
europe ecologie les verts et pour
l'annulation de l'arrivée du super métro
qui doit relier l'aéroport d'orly à
versailles
un dossier qui n'a selon la fédération
locale du parti jamais été viable et
notamment le tronçon en aérien à près de
magny les hameaux qui menace directement
l'activité agricole
la semaine dernière saint quentin en
yvelines avait adopté une motion pour
exiger la réalisation de la ligne 18 e
élevés avaient voté contre
transport transport toujours à mes côtés
routier c'est un nouveau chantier c'est
un chantier pardon inquiété dans les
cartons depuis 2013 un nouvel échangeur
sur l'a86 sera réalisée à hauteur de
vélizy villacoublay
comme vous le voyez en images il s'agit
d'un tunnel qui reliera le centre
commercial vélizy 2 au sud de la ville
et début des travaux l'année prochaine
pour une fin prévue en 2021
l échangeur permettra de désengorger
l'a86 et la n118
coût total 43 millions d'euros il a été
inauguré officiellement hier l'espace
bébé de l'espace bébé parents de
guyancourt et le 23e du genre en france
en fonction depuis un an ce lieu est
dédié aux parents et à leurs enfants
jusqu'à 3 ans pour répondre à toutes les
difficultés des familles en situation de
précarité bonsoir jean le guislain
bonsoir président de l'unité locale de
la croix rouge saint quentin en yvelines
la croix rouge qui est à l'origine de
ces espaces bébé créée en 2000 c'est en
2006 c'est primordial d'aider les jeunes
et je le parent on dans
dans leurs premières années parentalité
oui parce que bon on s'aperçoit que le
l'éducation des enfants commencent aussi
pendant les premières années et que plus
on se prépare tôt mieux les choses
peuvent se passer ensuite
un an qu'il est donc en fonction dans le
quartier des garennes à liancourt
l'espace bébé par an a été inauguré
officiellement hier je vous propose de
regarder ce sujet de camille lambert et
nicolas kirillovitch l'accueil est pour
le moins originale pour un local de la
croix rouge
les jouets les peluches et les couleurs
sont ici les maîtres des lieux
le nouvel espace bébés par an est ouvert
à guyancourt depuis un an il reçoit des
familles en proie à des difficultés
sociales et économiques
les moments les plus part du temps et
non pas de papa et c'est bien dommage
vont jouer avec leurs enfants et vont
pouvoir échanger avec d'autres mamans et
les enfants pourront aussi jouer avec
d'autres enfants est à voir comme ça les
premiers pas de la sociabilisation et
leur permettre de faciliter l'entrée
dans la scolarité un an près d'une
cinquantaine de familles ont bénéficié
des services de la croix rouge dans ce
nouvel espace en plus de conseils en
matière de nutrition infantile ou
d'hygiène les parents peuvent également
sous condition profiter d'une aide
matérielle ou vous avez l'ailé et petits
pots les vêtements et le matériel de
puériculture que nous offrons proposons
au moment qui en ont besoin
premier accueil du genre à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cet espace
bébés par an est installé dans le
quartier des garennes à guyancourt à
proximité du centre social local on est
dans un quartier où il ya une mixité
sociale importante où on va rencontrer
ddd structure pavillonnaire mais on va
rencontrer aussi plusieurs bailleurs
sociaux avec des gens qui ont des
difficultés différentes les uns des
autres
et cet accueil
bébés parents complète la teinte la
réponse à la tante de ces familles le
nouvel espace est ouvert tous les mardis
et jeudis matin les horaires pourraient
être élargies en fonction de la demande
et jean-luc glissement on l'a vu dans ce
sujet au delà de la mission dead qui est
apportée dans cet espace donc on va
aussi parler dans un instant l'idée
c'est aussi de créer du lien entre les
parents
oui tout à fait en fait on s'aperçoit
que souvent les mamans se retrouve un
peu seul chez elle parfois ce sont des
femmes qui sont très actives au travail
qui se retrouvent pendant plusieurs
semaines voire plusieurs mois avec un
bébé
on le bbcc occupe beaucoup nuit pas à
plein temps et donc le fait de pouvoir
échanger avec d'autres mamans avec des
bénévoles et souvent des grands mères
qui peuvent donner quelques conseils qui
peuvent expliquer leurs expériences qui
peuvent éventuellement
le fait de participer aussi à quelques
ateliers spécifiques permettent aussi de
de recréer ce lien social
donc ça c'est important le deuxième
point important c'est que ça commence à
se socialiser l'enfant parce que s'il
reste tout seul dans l'appartement avec
sa avec sa maman on évidemment la voilà
le début de la scolarisation enfin le
fait le fait pour lui de commencer à
devoir comprendre que de temps en temps
il faut partager que quand on a dérangé
bas il faut ranger un petit peu après
derrière et tout ça et c'est une
préparation à l'entrée à l'école
maternelle ensuite qui est assez
intéressante pour les familles je vous
l'aï dit une vocation aussi à donner des
conseils puisque cette période de
parentalité le début de la parentalité
et pas forcément facile déjà quand on
est parent mais encore plus quand on est
en situation de précarité mais non il
n'ya pas d'école départ on serait un
donc on n'est pas préparé à être parents
souvent on apprend sur le tas ou en
demandant des conseils à droite à gauche
là c'est une structure où on peut avoir
des conseils et parfois découvrir des
solutions qui ont été été trouvé par
d'autres qu'on peut appliquer qui sont
intéressantes
on a fait un lan ateliers de langage des
signes par exemple pour les bébés
naissants j'allais vous lancer sur les
ateliers cas quels sont ils
quels types d'ateliers alors bon c'est
trois et six variables selon les la fois
les des animateurs qu'on peut trouver
et puis d'autre part l'intérêt que les
familles peuvent peuvent porter bon là
on a eu un dentiste qui est venu
expliquer les
les avantages d'une saine hygiène ducale
pour les bébés parce que ça les prépare
aussi pour le futur on est bon ce une
diététicienne qui est venu expliquer que
bas les petits pots c'est bien mais un
petit pot c'est un euro 20h30 un euro
cinquante si vous faites une purée de
carottes et pommes de terre c'est bon
quand on allait voir qu'il ya d'autres
fallu 25 centimes et en fait c'est plus
économique tout en étant plus naturel
donc il ya des petites choses comme ça
bon ce sont parfois des vérités
évidentes mais se fait pas toujours de
mal de se leurrer entendre dire et
expliquer alors l'espace a été inauguré
officiellement hier il fonctionne depuis
un an on l'a vu dans le sujet il a
accueilli une cinquantaine de familles
en un an ça fonctionne bien est ce qu'il
ya des potées des pistes encore
d'amélioration pour cet espace ils
vivent une piste d'amélioration c'est
qu'on va ouvrir d'autres demi journée on
est à peu près certain que d'ici
quelques semaines on va être en mesure
d'ouvrir le mercredi matin
probablement aussi le vendredi matin
s'est rapidement d'accord
l'espace est à la fois grands et petits
si on compare pas y mettre 250 familles
se présenteraient aucun intérêt de
l'arrière donc pour rester sur des
petits groupes préfèrent multiplier le
nombre de journées d'ouverture
vous l'avez dit peut-être une ouverture
le mercredi j'imagine aussi que lindsay
local saint-quentin-en-yvelines
recherche encore des bénévoles pour pour
aider aussi dans ce local dans ce dans
cet espace est aussi à d'autres missions
sur le territoire oui bien sûr oui on
est toujours en recherche de bénévoles
de la croix rouge de saint quentin est
hyper active sur le territoire donc on
recherche à renforcer nos équipes un peu
partout de temps en temps certains
bénévoles prennent un peu d'âge donc ils
ont besoin de pouvoir commencer à se
reposer un peu donc on cherche cette
aide là et puis partant seul engagement
et voilà et donc ça heureusement ce
les missions que nous offrons à nos
bénévoles sont diverses et variées et
intéressantes et donc ça permet de
trouver pour le bénévole qui veut donner
un peu de temps de trouver une activité
intéressante dans lequel il peut
s'engager
merci jean luc israir d'avoir est avec
toi je le rappelle vous êtes le
président l'unité locale de la croix
rouge de saint quentin en yvelines merci
pour avoir parlé de ce sujet l'espace
bébé parents qui a été inaugurée
guyancourt je rappelle également que
vous pouvez toujours apporter votre aide
aux victimes de l'ouragan rma aux
antilles pour cela faites un don sur le
site internet de la croix rouge qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
ils ont fait leur entrée depuis le 11
septembre dès le début du semestre les
étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines ont reçu et
des visiteurs de choix des journalistes
coréens sont venus découvrir l'activité
des surligneurs à la faculté de droit de
l'ue vers ce qu a dû en cours nicolas
landry ils sont venus de corée du sud
pour rencontrer les surligneurs douze
journalistes de plusieurs télévision
coréennes ont découvert le légal
checking la vérification des
informations à partir du droit la
spécialité des surligneurs de
l'université versailles saint quentin
les personnes qui ne sont pas dans le
milieu journalistique ou qui ne sont pas
reporter sont très exposées aux fausses
nouvelles et aux fausses informations
je pense que c'est notre travail en tant
que journaliste de faire cela et de
filtrer les fausses informations pour
nous téléspectateurs
donc je pense que c'est très important
d'avoir des personnes qui vérifie les
informations et des personnes qui
vérifie la vérité juridique des
informations avant que les fausses
informations
en général je pensais que le fasse chez
king c'est quelque chose qui est fait
pour les journalistes mais aujourd'hui
j'ai appris qu'à l'université avec les
juristes
on pouvait collaborer pour faire ce
travail à partir d'exemples concrets
vincent couronne explique la
méthodologie des surligneurs la parole
des politiques analysés par les juristes
une méthode qui intéresse les
journalistes coréens notamment à cause
de la destitution de l'ancien présidente
par gianni et suite à une affaire de
corruption et d'abus de pouvoir en mars
2010 est le poids de beaucoup de
questions sur
la légitimité qu'on a à faire ça et
notre processus de
de travail c'est à dire comment est ce
que nos sélections de l'information
comment est-ce qu'on nous mettrions et
comment est-ce que nous assurons de la
véracité de l'objectivité de ce que nous
écrivons par ailleurs les surligneurs
ont lancé une campagne de financement
participatif pour récolter des fonds et
permettre de se développer et nous vous
en parlions dans les types une
colocation particulière a ouvert à
versailles en début d'année proposé par
l'association maison saint-joseph et la
fondation pour le logement social
elle s'adresse aux handicapés mentaux
une maison qui peut accueillir à cette
jeune 5 ans bénéficie actuellement
mélanie poker les a suivis et anthony
dans cette maison de porchefontaine
c'est l'heure du repas anthony louis et
françois sont en colocation
rien d'anormal car ces jeunes âgés de 19
à 26 ans les une particularité ils sont
atteints de trisomie 21
cette maison jean paul ii est un lieu de
vie où sept garçons font qu'à vivre en
colocation dans un esprit familial c'est
à dire qu'ils ont chacun leur chambre
c'est leur propriété privée entre
guillemets y seller chez eux mais il y à
1,2 commun une idée née pour accompagner
ces jeunes vers l'autonomie à travers
des gestes simples comme mettre la table
parmi les acteurs la fondation pour le
logement social qui à acheter et
aménager la maison la fls investi plus
d'un million d'euros nous sommes
l'association immobilière et nous
mettons à disposition ses biens
immobiliers et donc nous les mettons pas
à la disposition des handicapés humaine
mais alors que la disposition d'une
association qui gère familialement ces
handicapés c'est la raison pour laquelle
si vous voulez où les loyers qui sont
pratiqués sont des loyers du marché dans
le cadre du logement social
chaque famille verser 950 euros de loyer
de salariés des maîtresses de maison est
de la gestion des activités et des
sorties sont organisées quotidiennement
c'est la première maison de vie et de
partage en france une autre manière de
s'alimenter et de consommer les pieds du
routard a ouvert ses portes à guyancourt
dans le quartier du pont du rotois
recettes une épicerie participative qui
a pris place dans la boulangerie des
petits pains grommelant bonsoir
excellent ribot adhérentes de la sauce
régale à l'origine de cette initiative
alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
le le concept d'épicerie participatif
finalement quelle différence avec une
épicerie ou un commerce traditionnel
l'épicerie participative c'est un
groupement d'achat sont des adhérents
qui se sont rassemblés pour pouvoir
manger sain et local au maximum pour
cela ils se sont ils se sont accordés
pour pour avoir un maximum pas de
salariés salariés pas de makokou de
manoeuvre donc
chaque adhérent participe à la gestion
de les pistes donc ce qui permet
d'acheter les produits a appris à prix
grossiste et donc avoir des produits de
qualité de qualité de un moindre coût
des produits auprès de producteurs
locaux par exemple près de paris par
exemple auprès de producteurs locaux
maximum d'accord c'est ce sont des
produits qui sont acceptées par tout le
monde
tous décident décide des produits
cookies sont acceptés dans l'épi et donc
les adhérents les adhérents acceptent de
donner deux heures de leur temps par
mois pour en en retour en contrepartie à
avoir laissé prix de caisse et des
primes one pour des produits de qualité
donc le côté finalement participation
s'engager pour pouvoir bénéficier de ces
prix intéressants alors à l'origine de
cette épicerie il à votre association la
sauce régal qui a pour but de mettre en
oeuvre des pratiques alimentaires
collectives participative et
alternatives ce mot est important
pourquoi pourquoi cette conviction la
soirée gala d'abord partout pour
conviction de protéger l'agriculture
locale un maximum et part du principe
que le meilleur face aux façons de
protéger l'agriculture locale c'est la
route c'est de l'art en direct au
maximum en circuit court pour les pour
les citoyens
donc pour cela la salle nous avons
cherché à développer plusieurs circuits
courts et en plus on valorise valorisant
par des interventions et des
interventions festive et conviviale dans
la ville mais concrètement qu'est ce
qu'on peut trouver du coup à l'épi du
rotois dans cette liste on va pouvoir
trouver de la compote la compote en vrac
qui sera qui arrivera des vergers
normand transforme elle transformée à
villepreux donc directement avec le
producteur on va pouvoir trouver trouver
des savez quoi des savons de qualité on
va pouvoir trouver des brosses à dents à
tête changeable d'accord
et le truc produits dans un rayon plus
ou moins proche c'est ça aussi l'idée ça
un accident et surtout de la qualité du
le plus proche du bio tu que possible et
simple et pour monter cette épicerie si
on revient sur le balbutiements du
projet la préparation il ya eu des
actions qui ont été organisées pour
pouvoir par exemple récolter des fonds
qui ont servi à l'ouverture de cette
épicerie oui par exemple nous avons
organisé une projection une projection
débat qui s'est déroulé à accuser
déroulait donc à guyancourt
le 10 juin dans lequel on apprend qu'on
a projeté le film food cote donc qui a
inspiré et qui a inspiré à l'origine du
projet des projets des villes épicerie
participative donc on a eu une 50e une
quarantaine cinquantaine de personnes
qui sont venues voir le film qui a
permis ensuite de partager et de parler
de l'épier d'attirer plus de personnes
d'ailleurs je suis un réseau d'épiceries
participative oasis et les petits
plusieurs épiceries qui porte ce début
de nom les petits alors c'est la lépi de
la vallée en vallée de chevreuse ou
celle épi du rotois or plusieurs
qu'est ce que tu portes le gars à
l'origine c'est le ch est aux forces et
l'épicerie l épicerie de l'épi castel
fortin qui a été initiateur du modèle et
ensuite qu'ils ont proposé à d'autres à
d'autres de partager leurs modèles pour
cela ils ont mis en ligne une plateforme
une plateforme internet ou que s'appelle
mon équipe point fr sa simple sur lequel
ils ont pu montrer qu'elles étaient les
méthodes à aller méthode assure
d'ailleurs l'adresse à l'écran dont vous
parlez donc ça a permis et a permis de
montrer quelles étaient les étapes à
suivre pour pour réaliser le projet et
ça permet d'inspirer d'inspirer beaucoup
de beaucoup d'autres qui se sont montés
merci avec ses rivaux d'avoir été avec
nous adhérente de la sauce régale à
l'origine donc de cette épicerie à
participative l'épi du rotor qui vient
d'ouvrir au quartier du pont du rotois à
guyancourt et plus d'infos sur le site
internet qui s'affiche pour nos
téléspectateurs
c'est une figure incontournable à
elancourt jean flattot et notre portrait
de la semaine
le président de l'association les amis
du passé d'elancourt oeuvre pour la
ville depuis 1987
ce week-end encore il a présidé la 24e
fête des vendanges à la ferme du
mousseau rencontre avec camille lambert
et nicolas landry alors avec maubeuge
oui voilà il y a encore quelques années
il n'était pas rare de voir des vignes
en ile de france et même à elancourt
aujourd'hui ces vendanges sont une
véritable fête pour la ville
cela fait 26 ans que jean flattot a
planté les premiers pieds depuis ils
oeuvrent chaque année en maître de
cérémonie
il ya des personnes nouvelles avec des
enfants en très bas âge aurait pu voir
la motivation malgré la bruine qui
tangue
c'est formidable n'est heureux parce que
en fait les objectifs de l'association
c'est festif ça va être ta fête
pédagogique et ludique
j'ai eu le jeu et vous aviez des
petits-enfants que trois ou quatre ans
les yeux pétillaient transmettre son
savoir jean flattot en a fait son métier
puis sa passion professeur de physique
et mathématiques au lycée il se consacre
à l'histoire dès 1987 avec son
association les amis du passé
d'elancourt arrivé en 1973 dans la ville
il est maintenant une figure
incontournable et on peut dire comme la
ville je me suis enraciné mais j'ai
toujours mon pied droit en franche-comté
d'où viennent les pieds de vie de
charcenne dans la haute soule
j'ai toujours été dans les associations
l'herbe c'est vrai que je peux le dire
aujourd'hui c'est pas toujours drôle
pour la famille parce qu'on est souvent
absent et puis à partir de cet
engagement j'ai été aussi élu 19 ans et
demi quand c est maire-adjoint des
encours il aime sa vie il a tout un
réseau d'amis dire l'elysée midi passés
d'eads en cours qu'il a créé
et avec toute une toute une équipe c'est
très important pour une commune ne pas
oublier ses racines
une équipe constituée d'une trentaine
d'adhérents qui s'occupe des vignes
chaque semaine après la récolte place au
pressage est au bilan
on dirait pas leur école du siècle mais
pratiquement on a une récolte très
importante en quantité et voir en
qualité est là il ya ces 30 vignes et
comme vous voyez derrière il ya eu sept
conteneurs remplis un de blanc lé 6
jaunes deux rouges et un rouge et pour
la partie technique cette fois c'est
joseph gonthier qui préside c'est lui le
responsable de la section vignes il a
rejoint l'association il y a cinq ans
j'aime bien moi le côté je veux dire
pédagogique
il est bon de faire attention la
transmission du savoir est en tout cas
de l'exemple les enfants sont étonnés
quand on leur dit que nous travaillons
pour eux en tant que bénévole une
découverte pour les enfants mais aussi
pour les adultes ses adhérents a pris
par eux-mêmes l'art de faire du vin une
expérience rendue possible grâce à
l'association et à son président
c'est un monsieur très déjà très
sympathique ouvert aux autres très
tolérant chacun s'entraide chacun amène
sa pulsion et puis petit à petit basse a
créé quelque chose de positif quoi après
une matinée de labeur une centaine de
litres de jus de raisin a été mis en fût
il sera mis en bouteille au mois de juin
mais les amis du passé d'elancourt ont
encore un grand événement à venir
en partenariat avec la ville jean
flattot organise le premier salon du
livre le 22 octobre 70 auteurs sont
attendus à la commanderie des templiers
avant de conclure ce journal c'est le
sport le plus populaire chez les
sorciers le quidditch arrive dans les
yvelines
cette pratique de harry potter dans la
saga de jk rowling un club a été créé
aux clayes-sous-bois cet été les aides
less and quidditch 78 nicolas landry a
enfourché son balai à rencontrer les
joueurs
que ce soit dans le monde d'harry potter
ou aux clayes-sous-bois contacter
vitesse sont les meilleurs atouts du
quidditch comme dans la saga on retrouve
les poursuiveurs les batteurs chargé des
cognacs et le gardien joueurs de
quidditch dans une équipe de l'essonne
gilles décide de créer aux
clayes-sous-bois un club les hedge-funds
au mois de juillet le quidditch ça
serait un mélange de rugby avec pour le
contacter deux enfants pas sages de bâle
et de cardio parce qu'on va courir
ok les batteurs dont qui en fait c'est
des gens qui ont un ballon qu'un pour
taper dessus pour taper sur les autres
doivent lever le ballon et le ballet de
l'équipe ont touché et repartir au
niveau des cages plusieurs apprentis
joueurs sont venus découvrir cette
activité
au programme un échauffement
entraînement à la passe et prise en main
du ballet vient ensuite la séance des
tirs au but d'abord avec un batteur puis
avec le gardien essayer de rester sur
son balai et puis essayer surtout de
tirer avec une certaine précision ce
qu'on a trois cerceau da différentes
hauteurs avisés et tout en étant en
mouvement et avec le ballon entre les
jambes donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
c'est assez stratégie qui est assez
compliqué les choses
je pense que c'est un sport qui est
vraiment qu'à radio déjà ça change c'est
pas de la course de fond
c'est vraiment cardio avec pas mal
d'allers retours c'est vraiment
intéressant dans le sens où il ya
plusieurs rôles
premier rendez vous pour le club des
clayes-sous-bois les 18 et 19 novembre à
limoges pour la coupe de france de
quidditch
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal je vous
rappelle une information principale
information
un accident impliquant deux bus qui
s'est produit ce matin à elancourt vers
10 heures un véhicule de la société sqy
bus on a percuté un autre à l'arrêt
bus à l'arrêt à l'arrêt rue du 19 mars
1962 et 19 personnes ont été blessées
légèrement cinq hospitalisées à leur
état n'est pas préoccupant une
défaillance de freinage serait à
l'origine de l'incident
nos reportages et le replay sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
l'application mobile tv 78 très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]